So what are the learning
goals of this class?
When we discuss our classes, learning
goals are the things that we want you to
know by the end of the class.
In this class, the learning goal is
really just that you would know enough
information to contribute to
the field of educational technology.
But of course,
no one can know everything and
no one can contribute
in every possible way.
So what you actually need to know will
be dependent on what you want to do
in this class.
You might want to design
educational technology.
In which case you really need to know
the current tools out there to address
the problem you're
interested in addressing.
As well as techniques for
designing sound pedagogical
strategies inside technology.
You might want to do
research in this field.
In which case you really need to
know the research methodologies of
educational technology.
As well as, what some different
communities out there have already
established in these fields.
You might want to do a mixture of both,
you might want to do user testing.
In which case you need some
research methodology but
some understanding of the tools as well.
Or maybe you're interested in
the broader issues of educational
technology, how it intersects with
culture or personal identity.
In which case you really need
to understand what those
community's theories right now are.
And the different strategies they go
about to understand those phenomena.
So what really matters in this class
is knowing what you need to know
to contribute in the way
you want to contribute.